a lot of people come to comic-con
dressed up so we asked a couple people
one of the do's and don'ts of comic book
costumes I think that all these people
should be encouraged to dress up like
lunatics at comic-con because everyone
suggested like a superhero all the time
so I say do wear whatever the you
want if you're gonna come in costume go
all the way because otherwise it's not
worth it one big don't I saw this guy I
don't even know what costume it was it
came out to like here and it draped down
he was like a king his walk he looked
kind of a short dude across the street
took was like three times as long
because we kept blowing him back he
basically was a sale first thing I'll
say is about the costumes whatever you
do when you're a comic con please
refrain from wearing a silly beanie that
obviously overtly promotes your band the
other thing is don't walk around with
the stake in your pocket you don't mean
who would do that that's just cheesy
what's the hardest part about being a
comic con is it keeping the chicks off
of you or not turning into a werewolf
hardly credible oh can you say something
to us in Navi not way in our way what
does that mean it's calm it means column
that's the only word I know awesome I
feel like the most important thing about
costumes for comic-con is cleavage so
the more cleavage the batter really is
that really better all about the
cleavage I love girls like if they've
got boobs like push them up get them out
there that's what comic cons about no
matter what your costume wear something
comfortable because Comic Con is
exhausting you are going to have a
costume and whatever fashion is going to
be and it's a onesie and you can't
really get out of it that easily put a
proper pee hole
that's a do is it hard to go to the
bathroom in that thing Oh Todd yeah yeah
you have a pee hole I do not do people
have check out your package I'm sure
they do don't dress while drunk I think
always dressed sober because it's
disastrous otherwise don't want to get
me upset or things are going to get
really ugly around here you're here
first folks insoles extra insoles are
definitely needed I would definitely do
a pee hole if I had though something
that had to do with spandex I would
watch where I'm going not like that guy
right just make a good deal just for me
is your eye patch real yes it is it's
still guy patch can we see if there's
like a so you actually are missing an
eye so what not to wear I'd imagine not
to wear Hitler I'll be pretty bad um I I
was the voice of Darth Maul in the
Phantom Menace and I've seen a couple of
Darth Maul's around you know and I think
that's something I'd quite like to do
you know shave my head red and black
paint money and some Brazil nuts on my
head because because of his mole nuts
thing to remember is that there are
children present you know i think that's
that's the point I was trying to make is
you know some of these things are really
left best best left at home at home here
yeah i would say that less is not
necessarily more yeah because we said
I've seen someone two women that really
ain't that wonderful I was I get to be a
vampire and not a vampire and all that
sort of stuff so I went through some
cool different costume changes for this
and I think we hit I think we hit that
part of it right i mean i had a blast
you know they're talking about the
costumes at comic-con right I
I knew that's good no people were in
costumes oh I got you I got it upsets me
when I see people snickering up both God
you think you're Princess Leia oh yeah
enjoy this is this is there this is
their day this is their show and i
celebrated I really do and don't take
judgment from who say you can
like you hey I went to a convention last
year just to have a little wander around
it was wizard world in Philadelphia so
lots of fat Darth Vader's and and I went
out to this guy he was just a Darth Maul
I went up to him and just whispered in
his ear at last we will reveal ourselves
to the Jedi at last we will have revenge
me as Logan me like do what's wrong with
him I was like I did the voice for you
know and I should have had to sort of
explain my son Heiser oh cool all right
would you like your picture with me